they wouldn't have outrun it my dad  would have been trying to put that uh  with a half inch garden hose and my mum  wrapped behind him saying would you want  me to throw his bowl of water  now they're gonna run that at eight  years you ain't  it runs it can go faster than me and you  can run  so they wouldn't have got they wouldn't  have  do you think they'll ever come back to  see it like this I hope they don't but I  wouldn't like him to see it like this  you know I'd give you best to keep the  memories you got aren't you  I'm lost for words I really haven't lost  words that ain't normally me you know  how did how did your parents take it  then how did you how did your dad take  it when she told me a pretty  philosophical I was quite amazed at you  know and and then to to compound the  should we say the situation dad took it  pretty philosophical as well  so